welcome back to las vegas now today is
national cheese and wine day one of my
favorite days so who better to celebrate
with than valley cheese and wine owner
aka the wonder woman of cheese diana
thank you for being here hi thanks so
much for having me i always have so much
fun when you're here
and you always come with cheese and wine
so this is why i love you
it's a bonus it really is so you were
giving me a little sneak peek earlier
but these are some of just your favorite
reds and whites and cheeses so run me
through what we have today yeah i think
what better way to celebrate cheese and
wine day than by enjoying some of your
favorite things so i brought one of my
favorite bottles of white in the shop
this is a falun gina this comes from
campagna in italy
so it's where naples is the home of
naples it's great and it's got a little
bit of like stone fruit and some nutty
undertones a little bit of savory it's
just really really beautiful
yeah tree fruit like pear
so really gorgeous wine and we wanted to
pair it with an italian cheese so this
is moloterno de pecorino this is a
sardinian sheep's milk cheese grab a
bite of that okay give it a little chew
and then add some wine into it and
you'll notice that together they really
bring out like a little the salty
characteristic of the cheese you're
going to get a lot of playful fruit
notes that come through and come forward
there and it really is just a really fun
summertime pairing especially if you
enjoy salty nuttiness because it really
highlights that i could just do this all
day i have a question for you do you
count cheese as a meal like can i eat
this as my dinner absolutely cheese is a
pretty perfect food actually we can go
into that another time i thought you
would say yes to that so that's why i
asked okay this is delicious all right
and we have a red in front of us yes so
this is actually a really interesting
red i call this like a geekier style of
wine this is called graciano and it
originated in spain but it actually is
flourishing in the mclarenville area of
australia wow so this is an organic
biodynamic wine and it is just gorgeous
i call it a little bit more of like a
feminine style of wine making because it
has some like violet florals that show
through really bright red fruit and i
serve it with a little bit of a chill in
the summertime you can do that with your
light bodied red wines it's really hot
out so like put a light bodied red like
a cute little pinot in the fridge it'll
be really good for summer so it's okay
to cool it down a little bit i'm
smelling it as you talk about it and i i
never know what i'm smelling for but all
i can say is it smells delicious i'm
really excited about it but what cheese
are we pairing this wine with this is
sofa
tartufo so this is it sounds beautiful
when you say it
so this is a semi-soft cow's milk that
comes from truffle country in italy and
it has a small smattering of black
truffle the rind is actually coated in
ash coriander nutmeg clove and cinnamon
so it imparts a little bit of a baking
spice characteristic into the paste of
the cheese and there's just that essence
of truffle that really brings forward a
really playful earthiness when you
combine it with the gracie wow well you
had me at truffle so i'm going in for it
and as i grab a bite you gotta grab a
glass too because we are cheering to
some exciting things tell us really
quickly why did you anniversary too yeah
two years tell us about that while i'm
trying this so we bought the business in
the middle of the pandemic which was a
challenge in itself but we are
celebrating two years we didn't have any
parties when we first opened for you
know social responsibility reasons but
it's also the same day we bought the
business was my father's birthday oh my
god so we are having a big party this
year we are doing bottomless cheese and
charcuterie bottomless bubbly 10 of
everything in the shop we're doing
karaoke we're having raffle prizes
tickets are on our website
valleycheesenwine.com but it's just
going to be a blast we just want to
celebrate everybody who's gotten us here
and our community and each other and
we're really excited so it's a double
celebration congratulations to
everything you always know what you're
talking about happy cheese and wine day
i truly can't think of a better way to
celebrate them with you diana thanks for
being here we'll be right back